I'm like man I haven't done a good
enough job clarifying that when I talk
about work ethic I'm trying to speak to
people who are unhappy or complaining if
I could get people to think about their
careers the way they feel about waking
up in the morning and running for that
hour where they clear their stress they
love it I hate running so that doesn't
work for me but like for me working is
the happy place and I want that for
everybody because the big thing is I
don't think people really quantified how
many hours of their adult life isn't
actually working like think about how
much work takes up the time that you're
all week so a lot of people like all I
worked 9 hours a day I'm like yeah but
you also sleep 9 hours a day so that
means you work 9 hours a day and then
everything else you do while you're
awake is only 6 hours travel shower like
work is a lot of your life [ __ ] man do I
want you don't want to like it and live
it
enjoy it it's a lot dude look even if
you work nine to five if you work eight
hours a day and you sleep eight hours
day that means work is 50% of every hour
of your whole day
for 40 years of your life like why the
[ __ ] are you doing something you hate
make less money buy less fancy [ __ ] and
be happy like literally people are
miserable because of an extra room in
their house the comfort people come they
don't want to change it up yeah but you
know what I you know I think it's that
people buy should they don't need and
then have to work a job they hate to pay
for the shipping a little I hate that
[ __ ] it [ __ ] me heavy which is how I
got to the Joneses which is how I got to
don't worry about other people's
judgment the other thing is if you're 20
to 18 25 30 and you think you should
have your whole life figured out that's
ludicrous
I think self-awareness if you are
capable of accepting yourself for who
you are is actually the brightest light
of it all I love being something where I
suck at a lot of things
I just don't think about that like I
can't read for [ __ ] I interrupt people
when I interview them 24/7 everybody's
super pissed on the internet about that
not good there's plenty of things that
I'm not good at I love self-awareness I
like it's kept me so happy you know I'm
not upset at myself that I'm selfish in
certain areas
that's human I think that we just don't
love each other ourselves enough I don't
know whose perfection I'm trying to live
up to like silly things like people
getting on me for biting my nails kids a
[ __ ] where people just retweet
all day long like the sheer unhappiness
that I see on a day-to-day basis because
somebody else's opinion is dragging you
down
100% and and honestly it's a game of
other people's opinions whether that's
the anonymous comment whether that's
your friend who thinks you're selling
out after like you popped a little bit
whether that's me for me goes deep like
I can't hear anybody in this building
and and I think when people hear that it
can go into a audacity and delusion and
I respect that I think it's a I think
I've I walk a very tight rope and I
don't think on every day I'm always at
my best I'm sure sometimes I'm
delusional or audacious but it sure
beats being crippled by everybody's
opinions on an hourly basis which is the
[ __ ] masses
I'm big on squeezing as hard as you can
when you're on the field I love sports I
think a lot about it I'd be such a son
of a [ __ ] on the field but as soon as
game over I'd be like you know give dabs
and like but like when I'm on the field
I'm hard and so like I want people to
sleep sleep eight hours a day talk to me
about the 16 hours you're awake people
like oh I don't sleep I'm like no that's
not cool that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying when you're awake for 17 hours
like if you sleep four hours a day but
you watched three hours a day of [ __ ]
YouTube you're a [ __ ] idiot
like sleeps examined how her doesn't
make you a [ __ ] work like it's quality
and quantity but it all comes down to to
answer your question directly it comes
down to who you are it's become very
obvious to me that excuses are my poison
and I want to eliminate them at all
costs I took a lot about hustle and hard
work and people are kind of pushing back
on me a little bit right now and it's
been interesting I'm like man I haven't
done a good enough job clarifying that
when I talk about work ethic I'm trying
to speak to people who are unhappy or
complaining not happy with your job
don't watch Netflix work after hours
save money quit I'm not trying to get
people into depression or burnout I'm
trying to address unhappiness like if
you complain and you're unhappy I will
spend my career suffocating the living
[ __ ] out of you so you know like the
answer to your question whatever the
[ __ ] makes you happy at that point
and if you're at 26 right now I need to
prove to the world and most importantly
yourself that you're gonna [ __ ] do it
like [ __ ] work every minute of the
holidays if you're 31 and you worked
seven years of your life to get to a
place and you just had your first
go [ __ ] spent three weeks and see
every relative so they can rub little
Johnny's head like I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't have a point of view my point of
view is know yourself figure yourself
out and don't do it for anybody else
it's real it's very weak Sylar I hate
when people like yo Gary Vee been on a
bender nine days in a row haven't [ __ ]
slept I reply out I'm like don't do it
for me and definitely [ __ ] sweetie
like you know I just for me the thing
that's going to allow me to win the next
half-century and this is just the
beginning and I will not burn out like
people are waiting for me to do
something people are confused I hate
that people are pushing too hard against
hard work right now it's ideological
hard work as part of the equation I hate
when people work hard for 10 15 years
make a lot of money and then start
telling everybody else to just sleep and
meditate I'm like cool but don't be
[ __ ] ideological like tell your truth
like you worked so like now you made it
in your big shot like be careful like
don't be a hypocrite tab micro losses is
actually a very big part of being an
all-time great because the success is
the game itself back to the process you
know like I don't need the W's I like
the elves I like the W's I put myself in
a position to lose fights and I think a
lot of the people that are not going to
win to their capability are scared to go
into the ring
against a worthy opponent and they'd
rather not try just so they don't fail
because they worry about other people's
appeals I'm telling you and it's crazy
to be at this place in my life where I'm
like [ __ ] this all synthesizes down to
people worrying about other people's
opinions and oh [ __ ] that's why I didn't
do bad things in high school that my mom
asked me not to do because not the
prettiest girl in school
and not the biggest jock and not the
coolest kids none of their voices
penetrated my dome I'm looking for
people who are happy like I'm obsessed
with my process I just I wish people
loved their game their process people
that are possessed with the process not
the [ __ ] that the [ __ ] game buys you
because then you're finished right like
if you actually want them if you want
from the off White's
to the [ __ ] mansion to the private
planes to the spa treatments to the
girls to to the red carpet to the
dresses and gowns the jewelry then you
don't have a long career but if you
can't breathe like that's why
entrepreneurship is so weird to me I so
couldn't breathe then I wasn't even
capable of getting C's in high school
because I would suffocate giving school
even another second of not me being in
my own head of how to sell wine or
baseball cards people who can't breathe
if they're not doing their art and for
me businesses my art and for other
people it's art in other people it's
designing other people it's performing
on stage I need somebody who's obsessed
with their craft and would be doing it
for free quote unquote
no matter what
I'm telling you man it's crazy to be at
this place in my life where I'm like
[ __ ] this fall synthesizes down to
people worrying about other people's
and oh [ __ ] that's why I didn't do bad
things
that my mom asked me not to do because
not the prettiest girl in school and
that the biggest jock and that the
coolest kids none of their voices
penetrating my dome so if I can get them
high school
real life's measly
[Music]
[ __ ] happy make it so much happen
it just feels exactly right vlog I love
you thank you so much for watching this
[ __ ] this journey means a lot the
feedback the comments subscribe if you
haven't please
[Music]